we need to we need a flirt yeah yeah we
can't [ __ ] on the first date you know
that's let's build it up you know but
that's not you Joe I do it the opposite
yeah your first date coming back your
salad tossed on the first day oh gotcha
this guy's uh you know there's like
swipe right for most people it's just
like spread right
[Music]
about
to be careful boys with a lot of ladies
here and more importantly we've got a
new guest Mr Jesus
so I saw you recently on a genius brain
with the David Good Old David and you
mentioned that you actually used to
watch when David was on a better show
called just kidding news yeah oh yeah
dude shots fired and I like it yes dude
yeah when he used to be funny you know
what I mean in the show and I was like
oh he was killing in this show once he
left I'm like oh what's going on
all of a sudden you get so serious and
he's just like yeah I don't [ __ ]
understand that's why he dropped the
comedy there's no David So comedy it's
just Dave is so serious man like if it's
so serious all these people on YouTube
are like oh because you're beefing I
knew it I knew it everything they wanted
I love that [ __ ] yeah I did I know yeah
so you used to watch the show yeah I
used to watch the show a lot dude I
actually have a it's so funny dude but
we actually got booked I do Stand Comedy
so you got bugged no way we did this
college uh show right when you guys were
like like like popping like right when
everything was like yeah because you
were doing like a band or something like
that you were dressed up like uh is that
the one in Long Beach yes and Long Beach
yes for the [ __ ] Long Beach oh [ __ ]
yeah because we had a we had a
Vietnamese funk band Yes yes what
corny dudes doing you know I don't know
did they big time you yeah oh big time
Big Time well and you know what because
I think you were nervous I think you
were nervous
no dude and I was just like all right
don't you love how us Vietnamese people
share our culture and that's not
appropriation at all yeah hey you go be
successful when you'll be successful we
were called the uncles and the refugees
wait who's in your band we formed the
band two weeks
before we [ __ ] decided to do this
show no way that's why we were nervous
we just
the whole time I thought you were an
[ __ ] he's in his own head dude yeah
he was in his own head yeah just made a
song we were trying to memorize the song
still because you know like when you're
that age you don't you don't work hard
yeah yeah you're just showing up yeah
you probably practiced 30 minutes a week
oh yeah yes yes that was so that was us
right so we procrastinated and then the
day before the show we're like [ __ ] I
still don't know the lyrics bro no way
and then I barely learned how to play
guitar like everything was last minute
oh no dude I could tell you trust me I
could tell
bars no rhythm there at all and we had
our uh there was a Vietnamese in the
group his name is Tony and I think he
was the keyboardist oh yeah nice or was
he the based no no and I don't know if
Jackson was there but he had a black guy
okay I think so I'm not sure dude yeah I
think so you're allowed to do the funk
part yeah yeah yeah no that was the funk
part of the show yeah right he was the
only guy that was really playing yeah
that's the street cred yeah they're like
we can call ourselves Vietnamese [ __ ]
because we got I don't know what his
role is but the black guy yeah he was
like you know how the an orchestra you
have the instructor to get back and beat
the black guy with the back and beat you
know he was keeping him on Pace right
he's a Metro he was the Rhythm yeah
I wouldn't know no you had the voice
that you mimicked um like uh yeah I mean
I could do this I I don't even remember
what the song was and I don't you
because like you know when you cram for
a test you bust it real quick right and
then you forgot some words oh yeah and
and you forget what you did I really
would if if I remembered I don't
remember what it was but you did great
though I'm shocked everybody loved it
that's crazy yeah dude yeah it was not I
remember because I remember you guys
were like popping on YouTube and that
was like uh right when you guys were
like I'm like starting a hit because
like we that was just kidding films days
when we first started doing sketches
yeah back when you guys were cool with
David and stuff you know that was like
the The Click was tight you know what I
mean that must have been 2008.
everything's fragmented that must have
been 2008 I was I was a college student
2009 2009 when I think I that happened
but eight or nine yeah yeah okay yeah
that was crazy dude that's a minute ago
wow and I remember seeing you guys and
I'm like everybody loved it everybody
went crazy they the character whatever
and I Remember on YouTube I looked like
what the [ __ ] and I'm just like oh I get
it I see what you guys are doing here oh
that's cool you're like how's this
shitty ass yeah
he's gonna hate me as a comedian no as a
comedian I was hating because I was like
YouTubers oh [ __ ] they're not real
Comics they came up as Comics that was
what I was angry about the fact that
they announced the voice as Comics I'm
like [ __ ] these guys they're not Comics
yeah they called us a comic and we come
out as a band Yes
a Vietnamese wait Joe was that your
first and last performance
we did too after that we started getting
booked as a pet
who did the parties and stuff
and stuff like what do you call it the
not the Palladium the um the oh [ __ ]
it's the outdoor right here modern part
though oh it's a monitor Park one yeah
the amphitheater the amphitheater yeah
Amphitheater with the modern Park
Amphitheater not the LA one it sounds
[ __ ] cool please tell me you guys had
merch for your band
no we did we just we just sold the JK
merge but I'm telling you this band
started and disappeared like that though
yeah but I think we have a performance
online though if you want to see it at
the amphitheater it's called the uncles
and the refugees I think that was really
funny the girls in the refugee but it
was funny you guys did pull it off
though you guys were funny and then you
were like riffing and talking to girls
in the front and then telling them how
you're you're disappointing your mom
because you're doing the twerking and
this and he's like yelling at her and I
was like oh these guys are really funny
I was originally there it is doing a
charity a charity concert to support the
this sgb to support this thing you found
it dude I finally we finally did the
black guys
that was a different this this was
probably our second show so the first
one
for sure
yeah that was you right yeah that was me
with the guitar yeah wow you guys got a
pretty good crowd yeah and I'm the uncle
Chen
[Music]
hey guy get rid of the instruments
because I'm not hearing no music it's
mostly talk there's music he just he was
about to play it no I'm glad he turned
it off though trust me music's not that
great dude I don't even remember the
comedy was good he did the right thing
when the music came on turn that [ __ ]
off right right away dude no but it was
it was definitely funny though this is
before you're yeah you're a part of JK
yeah yeah way before yeah you know I
think you guys are like the ogs of that
like of a click blowing up on YouTube
and making like money on YouTube and
doing that because like now people are
doing it yeah you know but you guys were
like the first ones that started like
having a crew and becoming and starting
your own like company you know what I
mean yeah is not easy I wish someone
else did it before so we could just
follow their footsteps but then we made
so many mistakes so many mistakes now
you think back you're like damn what is
like the dumbest expense that you did
you're like why did I we paid how much
where do I start dude but the one that
like really haunts you you're like I
can't believe I wasted that much money
on something so stupid I think we wasted
about uh
you're just staring at them hard well I
don't know if it's a waste because it
was a business there was a business
expense but we basically spent close to
700 Grand on a on an office space
a hundred grand 700 Grand on the office
space
and then a set but I mean like it's for
the business holy [ __ ] and at the time
we were thinking about it because half
of them were like yeah
you guys are thinking like I said 100
you could have just gave me eight
thousand eighty thousands son of a [ __ ]
they would have been in my backyard only
she was a part of that era we're all new
WoW but that that time we had like four
five channels we wanted to be our own
network we wanted to expand we wanted to
go bigger so we were building the
foundation to do that yeah but not in a
smart way because like that you we could
have just bought a house with that money
and turned that into that's what I would
do it now if I could do that over again
I would split that money up into several
homes and turn them into different
offices I was gonna I was gonna say dude
sell that [ __ ] when I don't need it no
more yeah that's a pretty big mistake
because the office yeah you know this is
like this is like eye-opening it's crazy
dude like for for being Asian you're a
terrible businessman
I never got into business for business
like I got into all of this for fun so
then everything was to support that dude
that pisses me so that pissed me off so
much when people just make so much money
I didn't even [ __ ]
I didn't
know yeah I've got so much freaking
money right now and I'm over here
Starving Artists like I'm trying to do
my best I get my own
[Laughter]
sure why not even after expanding and
having the set like people hated it
really oh that's even worse why did they
hate it so it was too much of a glow up
you know is that what it was look at
this look at where we come from that's
why we still film here well like I think
back then too like now everyone has
professional sets but back then people
liked the closeness on YouTube yeah the
rawness oh so you guys you guys think it
was just too early I think it was too
early but also I get where the fans were
coming from at the time because they
didn't see the process so that's the
difference is like when you see other
YouTubes YouTubers do the globe they
don't just like go ladies and gentlemen
and unveil the curtain say voila like
like they would see the building they
see like why we did it this way and then
like they understand it they're a part
of the journey and then they go oh okay
we were we were for the ride I got you
yeah and I and I think that's where we
[ __ ] up as like well we know this as a
YouTuber we know the the journey is the
most they want to be included but then
we just were like let's surprise them
it's gonna be so sick he did not want to
be surprised they were like what the
[ __ ] is this you look like a TV show I
don't want you to [ __ ] be I watch TV
if I want to watch TV yeah yeah foreplay
brother play dude she was winning raw
doctor you're like
so that that time it's a good way to say
it you know what I mean yeah exactly how
I always go back with sex it's like
that's a strategy [ __ ] the foreplay they
like cut that part out of the business
dog we need to we need a flirt yeah yeah
we can't [ __ ] on the first date you know
that's let's build it up you know but
that's not you Joe I do it the opposite
yeah you're a first date coming back
your uh salad toss on the first day oh
gotcha this guy's uh you know there's
like swipe right for most people this is
like spread right I even saying about me
today
we're here to get to know Jesus I'm just
trying to give him contests we gotta you
know this we're getting to know each
other this is flirting yeah we go way
back this is flirty yeah right that's
how we flirt we've known each other
since 2009. it makes it interesting he
bought me coffee you're doing the right
thing dude yeah I might give it up by
the end of the show yo look at that I'm
introducing him to the Vietnamese
culture which is not mine the hardest
bread I've ever tasted with the
Vietnamese sandwiches like God damn is
that's the French people oh is that what
it is that's the French people I lost
like three hard on us I don't cut your
upper lip but it's fine once you get
used to it you're good because you just
turn it upside down it's a roughly hard
side on yourself I want to ask you so
that moment right when you saw this
[ __ ] group of [ __ ] goofballs yes
like were you like what kind of show am
I on yeah no I was like yeah did you
like think less of yourself were you
like I can't believe I'm sure I was
legit I was just like oh these guys are
not gonna make it because it was just
ridiculous it was all over the place and
like they're trying to be jackass I
don't know what's going on you know
hatering a little bit and then and then
you guys [ __ ] ended up just like
blowing the [ __ ] out and I'm like oh I
guess I was completely wrong you guys
are like super [ __ ] who booked you
for that one it was uh it was I remember
a friend of mine his name was a comic uh
comedian called Eli Nicholas I remember
he was the one that like hit me up and
was like yo you want to come to a spot
and I was like sure so I got on and I've
never seen a bunch of agents and I'm
like well I have a lot of Latino
material so I don't know how this is
gonna work but but we're all from L.A so
yeah so that's the thing that's all in
my head I'm like oh it's not gonna work
but it's like yeah
Latino material no but I just talked
about my family we all [ __ ] relate to
like that [ __ ] you know cheap dad you
know getting mad whooping my ass we all
know what's up that does get home if
you're immigrant parents they expect a
lot from you you know like she had to
wash rocks so that's pretty [ __ ] up
the what the what the what watch what
listen I don't want to talk about it oh
man I can just see the depression in
your eyes what's going on talk about it
last time she shared Anthony's [ __ ] all
over her no Diddy uh I took a [ __ ] on
her chest is what he's saying hey yo I
don't want to talk about that show me
[ __ ] liar because you have Clips or
what you know what's funny uh when I
first saw you on the call she uh or not
on call she when uh Bart said that you
were coming I didn't know if it was
Jesus of course I knew that Jesus could
joke was coming and it had to be you you
looked at the guy that would make the
Jesus joke for sure look it up that's my
only material I don't know
but start like him you know foreplay
with me dude all right and then you hit
me with this I do like this jacket
though yeah I will say I honestly did
you like this jacket this is really good
dude that's my foreplay how about you
guys ah [ __ ] I jacked his hipster at
a [ __ ] coffee shop dude that's a fact
he left it yeah and I was just like [ __ ]
him mine now guys
come on dude if he's got a story yeah
for sure that guy wasn't using it right
I'm like this guy's all [ __ ] [ __ ] on
this jacket you gotta clean it up put
some J's on it you know this guy was
[ __ ] with flip-flops why people are
doing weird things right why people
dress up so weird I know white people
right are you like it are you like full
white or are you just like no I got I
got some choices in me
oh you guys okay you want a bus you know
oh that's what's up
category yeah
how do you become thirty percent that's
actually 31.2
no this is check it yeah how does that
work this is this has been a reoccurring
lie that people keep thinking that's so
true I'm you know I'm just gonna did you
say the first that's because the editor
keeps on cutting out that part of the
explanation and and then do that again
here I'll make it easier for you 31.2
Chinese
wow you believe it I don't but it's fine
whatever helps you uh blend in with the
Asian crowd what kind of Ages
I don't know what kind of Aging yes he's
31.2 his ears are throwing me off I'm
like what's going on is that a disease
what the [ __ ] is happening is that
throwing me off they're called
cauliflower ears yo that's what it is
it's a type of Chinese
[Laughter]
martial arts and like go get away from
bullies and [ __ ] like you just have that
face that you got picked on a lot oh
nailed it nailed it
you know he nailed it what does his face
say what does his face
dude he looked like he was the stoner of
the group he knows the good drugs he
knows everybody who's selling drugs he
was that kid that would just be like he
no he nailed it bro nailed it to Julia
you're like the quiet girl who doesn't
like people but like is he like the
white girl I don't like people but I
like to be around people but then only
on your time and then you leave when
they were like you're over like I'm over
it that's it wow do you think that's
true Julian yeah that feels so opposite
but that's a relationship that's for
sure well I think at least that's how
Asian girls treat me you know what I
mean they [ __ ] all right now do
Anthony hey man it's not about me no he
went to everybody bro you got to come
hosting I'm asking questions this is me
judging people now dude I don't know
this guy because you're Jesus right
we're right that's pretty good all right
but what's your take on him he's like
he's like the cool nerd you know he's a
nerd but he's cool
do you think that's true
I'm just saying like are you [ __ ] he
can get into some nerdy [ __ ] and we'll
all be like oh we're lost dude I think
he'll like switch it up with some like
dope [ __ ] like oh that's what I'm
talking about dude don't talk about
[ __ ] cryptocurrency if I can talk
about some real [ __ ] [ __ ] and all
that [ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah that's that's
spot-on do you watch the show yeah well
I have to watch the show
my favorite videos I do watch yourself
so yeah I've been I've been studying you
guys for years that's why he nailed it
dude he doesn't watch the [ __ ] show
dude not religiously but yes but what
kind of Asian I don't know dude yeah I
don't know the just guess I don't know
which one it will a fan no no just say
anything okay can you use your like
language and let's I'll see uh English
is the English language
I'm That Kind of Asian bro oh you're the
[ __ ] the uh the Asian that people you
know all these ages hate this Asian
because you don't speak to you that one
they really do we're jealous of this I
want to say Filipino just because you
have a lot of people you look Latino a
little bit you know yeah you look like a
little cholo I didn't [ __ ] uh
ancestry.com and I'm 99 Chinese you're
just damn and one person not satisfying
at all he says Chinese is like oh that's
basic I feel like to me when I hear
Chinese I'm like ah yeah that's not
interesting it's kind of a letdown isn't
it
too many of them because it's like to me
it's like everybody's it's the go-to
everybody oh you're Chinese Chinese we
all like you know we all told Asians
they're Chinese so it's like it's so
basically Vietnamese I'm like what is
that what do you mean 30 99 31.2 so
where where are your parents from uh
they're from Mexico too hardcore Mexico
what part like Sonora I don't even know
if you don't know I know Mexico bro
isn't that where that cartel is yeah
yeah yeah I like that he likes that is
cartel that is definitely cartel you
know what's so funny like cartel is so
like normal yeah that to me I just like
yeah they're out there you got like
cousins in there oh yeah people got
kidnapped my family some people got
kidnapped yeah some of them get killed
but that's real [ __ ] though isn't it
yeah but you know that's what I'm saying
I'm just like and my mom will like tell
me on the phone like if it was natural
hey to your cousin yeah he got kidnapped
again
again okay okay again by the way again
and I'm like what happens though I can't
move [ __ ] [ __ ] move what happens
you know what happens they [ __ ] cross
the border when they get into too much
[ __ ] they cross it they come here they
start a family and just like in are in
the kitchen cooking and thinking about
their life oh I remember I [ __ ] got
kidnapped three times while they're
making your burrito in the morning
that's what happens the guy making your
burrito is the guy who he has cartel
stories for days wow
they're blending in with all of us they
kidnap and then they they ask for money
or what do they do or they're just like
I'ma kidnap you come fishing with me
because I need some friends you know
what it is
I'm sure that's what it is
one thing about the cartel they love
[ __ ] fishing the fishing in Mexico is
excellent dude is it really hell yeah
people go there for fishing Mexico
yeah dude so you got some cartel stories
you got some ah dude you got some family
member stories do you see them yeah not
yet I had a you know what's funny when I
was younger I was really into like my
friends for like really into like cartel
music and stuff with the abandoned stuff
that'll play so I would go invited to
these parties and I remember I got like
held hostage for like at least
I don't know how many hours it was it
was like all I I got there at [ __ ]
noon and I didn't leave until three
o'clock the next day that's a good way
to tell your parents if you're out at a
party mom you wouldn't I was I was
awesome
the thing is that they hire bands to go
after the club they'll hire a band to
play and they just party all [ __ ] you
know Mexicans we [ __ ] party you know
and they party all night they just have
a live band in the living room while
they're just [ __ ] talking and it was
fun but then they start doing so much
coke they get paranoid then the paranoia
kicks in and then he starts going like
he has cameras everywhere he's like hey
and they can shut the door ain't no one
leaving the house and I'm just like what
well I I gotta go
I I gotta go school tomorrow my family
has a cleaning business and we have to
start right at seven and my dad's gonna
be pissed you know so they have he
didn't want anybody to leave he was
paranoid he thought somebody was coming
after him you keep looking at the
windows and then he brought his guns out
and I remember going like what is
happening like I am not how old are you
when this happened I was like 20 or 19.
oh [ __ ] yeah dude I was like I'm here
for the band like I'm not a part of I
love the live music yeah you guys are
telling stories and just like huh you're
gonna tell me these stories about people
dying and getting heads chopped out and
I'm like dude I want to go home like I
don't want to be in this party no more
and then it was so funny like we all it
was so funny dude it was literally the
next day right I saw the sun come up it
was fun dude the crazy dude that that
was the craziest thing that happened
because I remember there's one moment
this guy comes in
bleeding all over his face just bleeding
and I'm like did some cartel [ __ ] happen
that's where my mind's going all
paranoid so you've got on my head I'm
thinking he got shot he got stabbed now
this guy was taking a piss on the side
of the house and his [ __ ] dog this
pit bull just jumped up and bit oh man
and just and then I runs inside and he's
bleeding and I'm just pretty crazy it is
[ __ ] crazy but it I'm telling you all
that happened that day I thought I was
gonna die I was like what is happening
this is too much and then you partied
with them the night after yeah right yes
and then you came back well at least
they fed you pretty good I was like and
there was music all they had was coke
they did not have food I was just like
dude I don't want them I'm already
[ __ ] scared I'm dude I'm dancing
crying like I don't want to go home even
the girls were not like wanting to put
out now they're like dude we're [ __ ]
scared and I'm like [ __ ] there's nothing
for anybody here yeah dude we're all
trying to just leave the way we left was
that he went upstairs
to go like put everything away and then
one of the guys opened the door and then
everybody just what happened just took
off and we're like well I got into the
cars and we [ __ ] left that's so
[ __ ] scary it was [ __ ] scary and I
think he's in jail now I I think I think
he's in jail now but that's Arizona baby
that's Arizona oh that's not in Mexico
no that's your that's it that's in the
states wow yeah that was in the states
Arizona he's like oh cartel party
totally different story yeah no dude
they're they're real dude they're out
that's wild yeah and tune in for more
cartel stories right when you come right
back
foreign